and since we are so close to that
general election and many groups are
working to get as many people to the
polls as possible
eight news now reporter kate houston is
live in the newsroom tonight with how a
local union is making its voice heard
kate yes sasha the local service
employees international union held a
rally today
they're encouraging everyone to vote
specifically focusing on the asian
american and pacific islander community
more than 30 members of the service
employees international union local 1107
gathered on south maryland parkway to
promote early voting
some of them doing it for the first time
i'm a first time voter and i'm dropping
this
cindy de los santos and her husband
became u.s citizens this year
she tells me she's proud to vote and get
involved
canvassing doing phone banking voter
registration
de los santos joined local candidates
and other seiu members at saturday's
rally
where there was election information in
seven aapi languages
the group kicked off the rally with some
speeches highlighting the importance of
early voting
they then took their signs to the
streets in an effort to encourage
community members to vote as well
booth on the ground grassroots yes
that's what we're all about because
we're
such a tight-knit community and then
having one person go and inviting
another person and another person i mean
that's how you get
the votes done many seiu members are
workers employed at local hospitals and
in clark county
the union tells me most have been on the
front lines of the pandemic
and are now on the front lines of the
election we believe in our union that an
injury to one is an injury to all
and so we want to make sure that
everybody is heard everybody gets their
voice
out and everybody votes today's rally
was part of a nationwide effort to
highlight early voting which spanned
across
50 cities pew research center says more
than 11 million asian americans will be
eligible to vote this year
that makes up nearly 5 percent of
eligible voters